I started getting D's and F's in 4th
grade I consciously walked into fourth
grade and said I'm out you don't want to
go to college you don't have to go to
college you don't want to be a doctor
you don't have to go be a doctor right
I think people value money too much
because they think because they think it
buys them happiness I don't think you
get the same returns by overwhelmingly
working on your weaknesses as you do on
tripling down on your strengths
need motivation watch a top 10 with
beliebe nation hey it's Evan Carmichael
and this channel was created to help you
overcome the number one challenge that
is holding you back a lack of belief in
yourself you watch these videos because
you know there's something more inside
you too you have Michael Jordan level
talent at something so get ready to have
self-awareness make sacrifices and love
the game with Gary Vaynerchuk and my
take on his top ten rules a success
volume 24 joy okay let's kick it off
with rule number one have self-awareness
entrepreneurship is scary and you have
to fight against the system and you have
to see things others don't and you have
to challenge norms and I quit school in
third grade you know like I did like
it's super weird but like I started
getting D's and F's in 4th grade I
consciously walked into fourth grade and
said I'm out I did I did and it was
mainly because for who knows why and I
really have no answer for this but I
just remember I mean fourth grade you
rich I mean you're a baby it's a it's a
it's I'm looking at like other for like
it's crazy to me that I actually had the
thought process of this isn't for me I
know who I am
I'm gonna be this and I don't care about
the periodic table
rule number two make sacrifices you
don't want to go to college you don't
have to go to college you don't want to
be a doctor you don't have to be a
doctor right but that also means that if
that's what your parents want and that's
what they're willing to pay for you
can't be like hey mom you know how
you're gonna give me eighty thousand to
go be a doctor that that's what you you
want well I don't want that I want to be
a painter so give me that eighty
thousand that's not I know you have to
leave that on the table that money that
infrastructure comes with that ambition
like if you want that safety and that
money well that means you're gonna be a
lawyer if you want to be a motorcycle
racer that means you're gonna live in a
studio apartment with 19 friends
people ask the dumbest it's kidney other
things like garyvee but how do you do
this in the Bay Area it's so expensive
like you moved you don't live in the Bay
Area
you have a choice pure like Gary look
looks like you're trying to pay $14 an
hour how do you survive in New York City
I'm like you live in Queens and you take
the like like you can do anything you
have options people aren't willing to
sacrifice for what they want rule number
three love the game I do not care about
money I love the game like people buy
dumb [ __ ] like I lately people been
coming at me a little bit it happened
this week and they're like wait a minute
wait a minute you keep telling all of us
that you didn't make any money but how
do you have money to invest in Facebook
uber and Twitter just like a thing
that's popped up this last week and I'm
laughing because I'm replying I'm like
cuz I lived in $1,100 a month apartment
that was a piece of in Jersey I went on
no vacations I bought no $4 coffee I
didn't buy anything
swag clothes and I've saved I made
41,000 a year the first three years of
my career and I saved 9,000 each of
those years in here make 70k year and
lose money each year because I got a I
didn't have a credit card until I was 27
I had a debit card cuz I wasn't gonna
spend money I didn't have I don't give a
[ __ ] about money I care about the game
so when I lose money I don't care cuz I
just don't care about it
I think people value money too much
because they think because they think it
buys them happiness like if people think
that people think that and I really
don't believe it
I really don't rule number four don't
dwell on your weaknesses I don't think
you get the same returns by
overwhelmingly working on your
weaknesses as you do on tripling down on
your strengths I don't know what else to
say like I read it it's so clear to me I
think so much of what I talk about is
predicated on not only my successes but
watching my family members watching that
whole ecosystem of startup founders just
watching I watch a lot I read a lot of
like people's behavior
more so than you know books or things of
that nature and so yeah I mean I just I
believe that the entrepreneurs that have
gone on to quadruple down on their
strengths and then hire around their
weaknesses have had much better success
than the ones that dwell on their
shortcomings because somebody they look
up to was good at it and said it was
important and they waste her time on
something they'll never be also if you
want to have more confidence motivation
and self-love check out my to 54 series
they're free the links to join or in the
description below
I really think mindset is everything and
so you've got a really design my ability
to only be comfortable in massive chaos
has been my biggest asset as an
entrepreneur like I would never take a
note like that scares the piss out of me
what these three people are doing right
now in a success world please understand
that success is happiness not net
dollars in remember 5 change your
perspective I'm unbelievably in tune
with the fact that it's almost
impossible to become a human being and I
have no interest for taking that for
granted
like like if I love with analytical
people I got so when I have a very
deeply math kid in front of me and we're
having some sort of debate and they're
upset about something I'm like you know
the odds of being a human being or 400
trillion to 1 right
like I think that what drives me is an
unbelievably clear perspective to how
lucky we are to have an at-bat and I'm
struggling to dwell and dump as long as
eight people that I love more than life
for a live that morning I'm in good
spirits I really have yeah you know like
look I think I think adversity and
humble beginnings is an incredibly good
framework to happiness if you layer
positivity and optimism around your
difficulty a lot of times people look at
their difficult thing dwell and go the
other way so for me it's not like I'm
excited every day because I get to play
rule number six prioritize culture
people who are driving down the culture
of a business should be they should be
there sir
I wish most businesses weren't to
documenting in coach
what most businesses are doing is
heralds of but his numbers are
remarkable
yeah that's what's really happening
that's what I'm referring to that if
you've got somebody who's driving
top-line revenue or as she or he is
rushing their numbers what most
companies are doing is they're looking
at surface level they're like ooh
if we fire Carol we're gonna lose those
three accounts because she's so wired
and they're but they don't realize is
the hidden lost revenue that's happening
with Carol or Harold destroying the
culture and completely messing up the
continuity and speed of the background
so what do you do from your point of
view what do you do if you have you have
someone who's really kickin that's
bringing the numbers in and they're just
they're a jerk what are you doing what I
do when one man's point of view is I sit
them down
I look up dead in the vase and I say you
think I'm joking because you're
delivering but I'm not joking and if you
can't be a good human being I'm going to
fire your face rule number seven grow
through adversity I grew up really lucky
in the fact that I had disproportionate
adversity in the first decade of my life
you know I was born in Belarus we came
to the US when I was three I lived in a
studio apartment with eight family
members you know it was super immigrant
right we didn't speak English like you
know my dad I didn't even know my dad
until I was 14 years old and started
working in his liquor store because he
woke up to go to work before I woke up
and he got home after I fell asleep I
went on one family vacation in my entire
life you know were - excuse me - in my
entire high school life both the Disney
World in Orlando
you know stayed in a Holiday Inn like we
kept it humble we didn't buy dumb [ __ ]
you know like you know I basically more
liquor t-shirts my whole life through
high school because they were degree
from the liquor store like the level of
humility and a lot of my ability to not
worry about others was predicated on
circumstance like you know and I really
think that I'm the beneficiary of very
good parenting and very lucky
circumstances and those lucky
circumstances in my mind was I was never
handed anything ever ever remember eight
be patient that's okay there's one thing
you want to throw everything
get up today Korea what would that one
thing it takes years a great creative
work to get to that place like stop
judging yourself just cuz this one video
then get as many views are not as many
likes don't judge yourself in the daily
judge yourself in the yearly and slow it
down be patient rule number nine love
losing
I love loosing like micro losing
especially more the macro losing is
incredibly motivating them you know I
mean there's nothing more fun than
losing regular-season games you know you
learn from them you know come the
playoffs you'd like to build on that but
yeah I mean I think adversity is the
foundation of success my losses are my
losses and my wins are my wins and they
both feel the same when I hear the
accolades or when I get razzed I
basically can't hear them I'm just so in
love with the process and that's and
that's what getting up off the floor is
you had no choice you just it's in your
DNA to want to play I mule number 10 the
last one before a very special bonus
clip is find true happiness the most
important thing I think about what I
think about getting to happiness is not
so much owning anything it's the ability
to not hear anything but yourself
there's nothing more powerful than when
everything gets quiet and the only thing
that penetrates is your own voice and
that voice isn't judging you now I have
a special bonus tip from Gary on how to
master your craft that I think you're
gonna enjoy but before that it's time
for the three point landing questions
let's go from just watching the video to
taking action here we go question number
one what does true happiness looked like
for you number two what's the adversity
that you need to grow through and number
three what's the weakness you have that
you need to stop dwelling on I do not
think anybody who goes to college and
studies entrepreneurship can beat me in
entrepreneurship that doesn't mean it's
right and it just kind of how my brain
works like I feel like it's a craft like
I I don't think like I think it as ask
we have not defied entrepreneur
entrepreneurship properly here's why
again I absolutely believe people that
go to school for Entrepreneurship can
get better at entrepreneurship from that
process I desperately believe that
entrepreneurship is a talent similar to
see singing and playing sports and I
think that I'm on that spectrum and that
gives me confidence in this one little
narrow thing of entrepreneurship because
while everybody else was studying in
school and like playing sports and doing
whatever they were interested in I was
constantly entrepreneuring right and so
I just have so much natural ability and
so many years of practice that I feel
like on the extreme and that's why I'm
confident about it Evan thank you so
much for having a couple seconds and
being able to tell the belief nation a
little bit about empathy whines it means
a lot to me that you would take this
valuable real estate and time on your
channel to give me some love
means a lot it's just good karma points
and so you're just you're awesome thank
you believe nation if you're into wine
at all go to empathy wines calm my whole
careers work was poured into producing a
wine that rivaled forty to sixty dollar
wine for twenty bucks a bottle
I'm just super
about this subscription-based wine
business you can order three six or
twelve bottles in subscription form Rose
a white red
if you cook if you search on Instagram
or Twitter you will be blown away people
are literally like I don't even like
Gary B but the wines good super proud of
the effort thanks Evan for the time
wishing you guys all happy and healthy
if you want more garyvee check out the
top 50 rules for success video I made on
him the link is right there next to me I
think you'll enjoy it continue to
believe and I'll see you there I don't
think there's anything wrong with
chasing money I just think that it's
usually the quickest way not to get it
work ethic is controllable